divine origin the word of God and they
are the most secret amongst all the
Hindu
scriptures next we
have we have the
upanishads there are more than 200
upanishads but our Indian
culture puts a figure of approximately
108 and there are some important
upanishad some say 10 some say 12 some
say 18 this upanishad which is
translated by radak Krishan he says
there are 18 principal
punishs
next we have the smis smiti means
memory that which is remembered and
these smis they are less authentic less
sacred as compared to the shuis the and
upanishad and they are not of divine
origin the Hindu Scholars say they have
been written by men for the guidance of
the human being how a life should be led
they also referred as the Dharma
shastra among the smti we have the
IAS the epics we have the two great
epics Raman and
Mahabharat ramayan is an epic which
deals with the story of shiram which
most of us Indians we aware of
it then we have the
Mahabharat
Mahabharat talks about a a feud between
the cousins the pands and the
K it also deals with the story of Shri
Krishna and all of us aware about the
story of
Mahabharat then we have the bhagwat Gita
it is an advice given by Shri Krishan to
Arjun in the battlefield and it is a
part of Mahabharat it contain the 18
chapter from the bishma par of
Mahabharat from chapter number 25 to
chapter number 42 it contains totally 18
chapters next amongst the Hindu
scriptures we have the panas we deal
with the stories of dieties the creation
of the universe it is compiled into 18
voluminous Parts by Maharishi vas and
most important among the puranas is the
bhavisha
purana this is the bisha purana which
talks about the future
there are various other scriptures of
the Hindus we cannot name all another
one is the Manus smiti the laws of the
Hindus which are written by Manu so in
short these were the
scriptures the books of
Hinduism but the
major are the
vas if anything contradicts with the vas
the vas should be be followed they are
the most sacred amongst all the Hindu
scriptures and they are considered to be
of divine
origin let's discuss the books in
Islam it's mentioned Sur chapter number
13 verse number
38 it
says in every age have we sent a
revelation there were several
Revelations sent by almighty God on this
Earth but the last and final Revelation
is the Glorious Quran
and it is the most sacred amongst all
the Islamic Scriptures it was revealed
to the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him 14400 years
ago it was revealed in
Arabic and Allah says in the Quran in
Sur sh chapter number 26 verse number
196 that it is assuredly mentioned in
the revealed books of the previous
people that means Quran is mentioned the
revealed books of all the previous
people other sacred books are the
authentic Hadith the traditions and the
sayings of the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him these
are supplemented to the Quran they are a
commentary of the Quran they will never
conflict with the
Quran they will never overrule the
Quran this is s
bukari which is one
of the authentic
books the sayings of the
Prophet fourth pillar of IM is the
messengers of
God first we'll discuss the messengers
of God in
Islam Allah says in the Quran in Surah
chapter number
35 verse number
24 there is not a people without a war
having lived amongst them in the
past Allah says in the Quran that there
were several Messengers sent on the face
of the Earth he also says inah chapter
number 33 verse number
40 which means Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the father of any of you men
but he is a messenger of Allah and he is
the Seal of the prophets he is the last
and the final messenger of almighty God
and Allah is all knowing full of
knowledge since Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was the last and final
messenger of Allah subhana wa ta'ala he
was not sent only for the Muslims or
only for the Arabs Allah says in the
Quran inia chapter number 21 verse
number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to the whole of humanity as a
mercy to all the the world as a mercy to
All
Creatures the message is repeated in
Surah saah chapter number 34 Verse
number 28 where Allah
says that we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving glad Tiding
and warning them against sin but most of
the human beings yet do not know and a
prophet said it's mentioned s bukari
Point number
one in the book of Salah chapter number
56 Hadith number
429 the prophet said that all the
previous Messengers that came before me
they were only sent for their people but
I have been sent for the whole of
humanity let's discuss the concept of
Messengers in
Hinduism the common Hindus they have a
different concept
they believe in
aars the word AAR is derived from a
which means down and th which means
Passover so AAR means to descend down to
come down and according to Oxford
dictionary it says that AAR means in
Hindu
mythology a diety or a revered Soul
coming down on the earth in bodily form
the common Hindus they believe that AAR
means almighty God coming on this Earth
as a human
being and this
concept they derive from bhagwat Gita
chapter number four verse number seven
and8 which
says it's a very common verse we hear it
on the television in the serial of
Mahabharat which means that whenever
there is decay of religion oh bhata and
Rise of
unrighteousness I manifest myself verse
number8 says to protect the good and for
the destruction of the
evil and to establish righteousness I
will be born in every
age I will be born in every
age this message is also repeated in the
bhagat
Pana 9 ADH 24 schloka 56 it says that
whenever there is decay of righteousness
and Rise of sinfulness I incarnate
myself but this concept of
AAR which most of the common Hindus
believe in it is nowhere to be found in
the vdas the most sacred amongst all the
Hindu
scriptures therefore the scholars of
Veda they say that the concept of AAR as
believed by the common Hindu is
different because AAR is a Sanskrit word
which is posive of almighty God it
doesn't mean God Almighty has come
himself down it is possessive therefore
it refers to a man who almighty God has
sent and if you read The Vedas no and
The Vedas is the concept of AAR present
but The Vedas speak about saintly men
about Richies who almighty God has sent
to guide the humankind this is exactly
same as the Islamic concept that
almighty God chooses a man amongst men
and communicates with them on a higher
level and these men who Allah has sent
to guide the human beings are called as
Messengers or prophets of almighty God
so if you consider the viic concept it
is similar to the Islamic concept that
almighty God has sent chosen men who we
call as prophets or
Messengers let's discuss
what do the Hindu scriptures have to
speak about the last and final Prophet
the antim
Rishi it's mentioned in the bhavisha
Pana
K three shlokas
10-27 it says that the malayas have
spoiled the land of the
Arabs there is the
enemy who's causing Mischief I will send
a man by the name of Muhammad to defeat
these enemy and to guide the people oh
Raja you need not go to the foolish land
of pachas I with my grace will purify
you here a person of injury disposition
comes to Raja and says
Arya D will prevail in the world the
religion of truth will prevail in the
world I have been sent by ishwar
parmatma and my followers will be those
who will be
circumcised who will not have a shande a
tail on the head they will grow a beard
they will create a revolution they will
give the call for prayers they will eat
all lawful things but will not eat the
Flesh of
swine they will not be purified by hubs
of shs but will be purified by Warfare
they will be called musalmans they will
be a Creed of
meaters now this prophecy if you analyze
refers to No One But the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him it says that the enemies will be
defeated by a man called as Muhammad his
name is mentioned peace be upon him and
he will guide the
people and we know Prophet mhammad
sallallah Al wasallam led the Arabs from
dark nness to light it further says that
the
followers of this Prophet referring to
the Muslims they will be people who are
circumcised they will not have a tail on
the head they will grow a beard they
will create a revolution they will give
the call for prayers that the aan they
will eat all lawful things but will not
eat the Flesh of
swine they will not be purified by hubs
and shs but by Warfare they will be
called musalmans they will be
a community of mediators all these
prophesies no one but Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and his followers the
Muslims Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him has been prophesied in several
places in bisha punana time doesn't
permit us to go into the details I'll
just give a reference of a couple he's
prophesied in bisha purana
kokas 5 to8 he's also prophesied in
bhavisha purana Par 3 K 1 AD 3 shlokas
21-23 the prophet Muhammad had even been
prophesized in several places in
Thea it's mentioned
inara book number 20 hym number 127
shlokas 1 to4 these are called as the k
suas k in Sanskrit means the hidden
glands in the abdomen referring to the
meanings of the shlokas are hidden they
will be known later on
due to shortage of time we'll just
discuss the first four in brief the
first Mantra says he will be
Nara he will be
Kama he will be protected from 6,090
enemies Mantra number two says he will
be a camel riding Rishi Mantra number
three says he will be Mishi man number
four says he is r
the first Mantra says he is narash
shansa narash shansa in Sanskrit it
derived from the word Nar meaning a man
or a person and
shansa means praise worthy how we know
in Hindi we say prashansa pansa is the
same thing so narash shansa means a
person who is praiseworthy and if you
translate Muhammad peace be upon him
from Arabic to English it means the
praiseworthy so narash shansa is the
Sanskrit translation of the Arabic word
Muhammad peace be upon
him the first Mantra further
says he is Kama one of the meaning of
Kama it means the prince of peace and
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
was the Prince of Peace the other
meaning of Kama is an immigrant and the
prophet migrated from Makkah to Madina
and the verse also says he will defeat
60,000 90 enemies and we know the
population of Makkah that was against
Prophet Muhammad Salli wasallam was
approximately
60,000 man number two
says he will be a camel riding Rishi
indicating he will not be a Indian Rishi
he will not be a Brahman because Manus
smti chapter number 11 verse number 202
says a Brahman cannot ride a camel or an
ass so this means it cannot be Indian
Rishi it cannot be a Brahman it has to
be a foreign isi a
foreigner man number three says he's
mamar Rishi also meaning Mahar Rishi
means a great
Rishi or some place that says Muhammad
that's the name of prophet MMI
wasallam the fourth Mantra says he is r
r means one who praises Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he was also called as
Ahmed may peace be upon him which means
one who praises and the prophet was
called the one who praises which is the
translation of the Sanskrit word
r he has been prophesized in several
other plac Ina he's also prophesized in
Atara book number 20 hymn number 21
verse number six it says that akaru
meaning the praiseworthy
man he will defeat 10,000 enemies
without a battle this refers to the
Battle of aab Battle of of kandak which
prophet Mah Al wasallam we know that he
was the one who was praiseworthy and he
won the Battle of kandak Battle of aab
in which the enemies were approximately
10,000 without the battle being
fought he also prophesied
in book number 20 himym number 21 verse
number 7 saying that the Abu by God's
help will defeat 20 Chiefs Abu means an
orphan it also means one who praises
both of this refer to Prophet M wasallam
and he will defeat 20 Chiefs we know
from history that approximately in
Makkah there were approximately 20
tribes so Prophet M sallah Ali
wasallam he won the Battle of Makkah and
defeated all these 20
Chiefs Prophet mm Salli wasallam is even
prophesied in rig book number one himm
number 53 verse number n the same
prophecy but the word is changed it's
called as suama and sush again means one
who praises the translation of the word
Muhammad Salli
wasallam the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is also prophesized in the s in
an Mantra number
64 it
says that he will not be fed by his
mother his mother will not breastfeed
him and after that he'll become a
prophet and we know it was Arab custom
that the children are normally
breastfed by the wet
nurse and Prophet MMI wasallam he was
breastfed pleas with
her there are various
Prophecies of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him in several places in
theas he is also prophesied in Sam in ut
mon number
1,500 it says that Ahmed will be given
the Eternal law Ahmed as I mentioned
earlier is another name for Prophet
mhmad Salli wasallam meaning one who
praises he will be given the Eternal law
referring to the Quran Sam says he has
been given the Eternal law but since
Ahmed is a non- Sanskrit word the
translators could not understand what is
the meaning of Ahmed so they broke the
word
into and M and now they translate as I
alone so it means I alone have been
given Eternal law so read the
translation it says I alone have been
given the Eternal law but actually it
should read as Ahmed has been given the
Eternal law and Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam had been
prophesized as Ahmed in several places
in the vas he also prophesized in The
Vedas in Sam in Indra Mantra number 152
he's prophesies in Jed chapter number 31
verse number 18 He prophesies in rig
book number eight himn number six verse
number 10 in atar book Number 8 himym
number five verse number 16 in atar book
number 20 himn number 126 verse number
14 in several places he has been
prophesized as Ahmed which was another
name of prophet mmad Sall Al wasallam
the one who
praises furthermore the last and final
messenger has been
prophesized as naranga in several places
in the vdas as I mentioned earlier
naranga
is derived from the word n meaning a
person or man and shansa as
prashansa means the praiseworthy a man
who's praiseworthy which is exactly the
translation of the Arabic word
Muhammad prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him has been prophesized at naranga as
Muhammad peace be upon him in several
places in The Vedas he's prophesized in
rig book number one hymn number 13 verse
number three in rig book number one hymn
number 18 verse number 9 in rig book
number one him number 106 verse number
four in r book number one him number 142
verse number three in rig book number
two himm number three verse number two
in rig book number five himm number five
verse number two in rig book number
seven himym number two verse number two
in rig book number 10 himym number 64
verse number three in rig book number 10
him number2 verse number two in yaj
chapter number 20 verse number number 37
J chapter number 20 verse number 57 J
chapter number 21 verse number 31 J
chapter number 21 verse number 55 J
chapter number 28 verse number two J
chapter number 28 verse number 19 J
chapter number 28 verse number
42 you can keep on quoting only
references he's been mentioned as
naranga in several places in The
Vedas you can only give a talk for
several hours together about Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him mentioned in
the Hindu
scriptures I'll just mention another one
last
prophecy he has been prophesized as the
kar the final
AAR the antim Rishi it's mentioned in
the puranas about
thear about his
coming it's mentioned in the bhagat pan
12 ad 2as 18 to 20 it says that in the
house of Vishnu Yash the rier priest
Brahman priest of the village of sambala
will be born
the it further says that he will be lord
of the worlds and he will have
unsurpassed qualities and character he
will be given espcially eight
criterias and he will be given by the
Angels a Ste horse a Fleet horse and he
will ride a white horse with the sword
in his hand he will defeat the misre and
the evil people and He will be savior to
the world it further says in bhagat
P
one ADH 3 25
that in
kug where Kings become robbers there
will be a savior who will be born in the
house of Vishnu Yash his name shall be
Ki he's even
prophesied in the K purana chapter
number two verse number four that in the
house of Vishnu Yash the chief of the
village of samala will be born
Karana chapter number
verse number five says that he will
along with four
companions defeat the evil
people chapter number two verse number 7
says that he will be helped by the
angels in the battlefield K Pana chapter
number two verse number 11 says that in
the house of Vishnu Yash in the womb of
suti the will be born and further says
in
kipana chapter number
two verse number 15 that he'll be
born on the 12th of the first half of
the month of
mad now all these
prophecies refer to No One But the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
sallah Ali wasallam Point number one he
will be
born in the house of Vishnu Yash that
means his father's name will be Vishnu
Yash
and we know that the name of the father
of prophet malli wasallam was Abdullah
Vishnu Yash means the follower the
obedient of
Vishnu and Abdullah means the obedient
the
worshipper of almighty
God his mother's name will be suti sumti
in Sanskrit means one who's peaceful and
the name of prophet m
mother was am which also means peaceful
it says he will be born in the village
by the name of sambala sambala in Arabic
means a place which is of peace and
security and we know Prophet mmad sallah
Ali wasallam he was born in Makkah which
is also called as Dar which means a
place of security and
peace it further says that he will be
born In The House of the chief of salala
and we know proph Sall Al wasallam was
born in the house of the chief of Makkah
it further says he will be born on the
12th day of the first half of the month
of
mad and we know that Prophet muhmmad
sallah Al wasallam he was born on the
12th of the first half of the month of
R it further says that the he will be
antim Rishi the last Rishi and we know
Prophet mammad sallallah Al wasallam he
was the last last and final messenger of
Allah subhana wa taala as is mentioned
in Surah aab 33: number 40 it further
says that he will receive guidance from
param in the mountain and then he'll go
towards the North and come back we know
he received the first guidance to
Archangel Gabriel in gahir in ja that is
the mountain of light and later he
migrated from Makkah that is northwards
and he comes back to Makkah later it
further says that he will have qualities
which are unsurpassed in character as
Allah says in the Quran in chapter
number 68 verse number four it says that
verily thou art stande on the highest
standard of character th are standed on
the highest standard of
character it further says that this Kar
will be given eight special qualities
referring to he will be
wise he'll have
self-control he'll have respectable
lineage he will also have revealed
knowledge he'll have Valor and
strength he will have measured
speech he will have the qualities of
being
charitable
and he will also be very kind all these
eight criterias and characteristics
refer to No One But the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him it fits his character exactly it
further says that Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him He will be given the Steed
Horse by Shiva and we know Prophet
wasallam was given the
B by almighty God by which he went to
Miraj the Ascension to Heaven it further
says he will ride a white horse and will
have the sword in the right hand we know
that Prophet Muhammad Salli wasallam he
took part in most of the
battles most of which were in
self-defense he took active part he even
wrote the C and had the sword in the
right hand it further says that he will
be a savior of humankind as Allah says
in the Quran in Surah f chapter number
35 verse number 24 and Sur chter number
34 Verse number 28 it
says that we have sent thee not
but as a mercy to the whole of humankind
and he has been sent as a guidance to
the whole humankind but most of the men
yet do not know he also said that he
will guide the people to the right path
and we know mammad Sall Al wasallam it
was the days of
yah and he guided them from Darkness to
light it further says that he will be
supported by four companions who will
spread the message and we know the four
companions mentioned refer to Abu Bakr
Omar us and Ali Allah be peace with them
all and it further says that he will be
helped by the angels in the battlefield
and we know in the Battle of
bad Angels helped Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam to win the battle
it's mentioned in the Quran in Sur Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse 123 and 125
it also mentioned
in chapter number 8 verse number 8 and
N these prophecies undoubtedly refer to
No One But the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he's
been referred as the last Rishi antim
Rishi the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad PE
upon let's discuss the fifth pillar of
Iman that is believing in life after
death believing in the yearafter first
we'll discuss life after death in
Hinduism the common Hindu he believes in
the cycle of birth death and rebirth
known as samsara the theory of
reincarnation and this theory of
reincarnation says that almighty God has
created different people in different
ways some are born rich some are born
poor some are born healthy some are born
with some effect so how could God be
unjust in making different people born
different ways so they came out with the
theory of samsara also known as theory
of
reincarnation or transmigration of Soul
based on the ver of bhagwat Gita chapter
number two verse number 22 which says
whenever a person changes his clothes
and wears new clothes it is somewhat
similar like a soul gives away the body
and enters new body
it believes in the theory of K the
actions that you do are the
K if you do good actions you'll be
rewarded in this world or thereafter if
you do bad actions you'll get a
punishment they also believe in the
theory of
DH dharm means a
person should live life according to the
guidance of almighty God if you do good
DM
then your Karm also will be good and
they believe in mosa that means free
from the cycle of birth death and
rebirth if you
analyze that this concept of
transmigration of Soul or
ssara is nowh mentioned in The
Vedas what The Vedas speak is about the
pun pun means next or
again J means life so pun J means next
life or life again it doesn't mean life
death and life again it's not cycle of
birth death and rebirth it's only next
life or life again so the Hindu Scholars
who believe in The Vedas they say that
the concept of transmigration of Soul
was never mentioned in the vas it came
into existence later on what is
mentioned in the vas if you read r book
number
10 himn number 16
verse number four and five it speaks
about the next life and also says you
will go to paradise but doesn't speak
about death life and
death further if you analyze the vdas
and the other Hindu scriptures they talk
about SW about heaven and describes
Heaven that it is a very beautiful place
where Rivers will flow there will be
Rivers flowing of milk and there'll be
various fruits it will be a place which
is good it is it even talks in several
places in The Vedas in Atara in R The
Vedas even speak about n that is Hell
the description is somewhat like fire
and it says that this fire of Hell will
be bad and a person won't be able to
Bear the pain in hell so the concept of
hell and heaven is there but the concept
of death birth and death is not there
anywhere in the
vas because the human beings the
scholars they could not know how could
some people be born healthy some people
born with conal defect so because of
this we find that this concept have come
about the birth death and
rebirth let's discuss life after death
in Islam and Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number
28 don't you know that you were dead and
he gave you life and then caus you to
die and then we again resurrected
you your Resurrection Allah mentioned in
the Quran is you come in this world only
once and again you're
resurrected and Allah says in the Quran
in chapter 67 verse number two
that it is Allah who has created death
and life to test which of you is good
inde deed this life is a test for the
Hereafter Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse 185 Allah says
that every soul shall have a taste of
death the final recompense is on the day
of judgment and those who save from the
Hellfire and get Garden in the life they
will achieve the objective of this world
for this world is nothing but mere
amusement and chatles of
deception the description of Heaven is
given in the Quran it describes that
there are many rivers in the Heaven
There are rivers of milk and there'll be
various fruits it a very beautiful
place and Quran also describes about the
Hell Fire Allah says in the Quran in
Surah
Bak chapter number two verse number
24 about the description of
hell and if you analyze in the
Quran as compared to Hinduism doesn't
have a philosophy that life death and
life again because some people are born
rich some people are born poor some
people are born with health
some people with kind
effect Allah says that this life
different people have different test and
depending upon different tests the life
will keep on
changing let's discuss the sixth pillar
of
Islam the sixth pillar of Islam is
Destiny
it's and Allah says that Allah subhana
wa ta'ala has certain things destined
for example when a person is
born where will he
die when will he be
born how will he
live like how the questions in the
examination it keeps on changing so
Allah subhana wa ta'ala has already
destined how will a person be born how
will he die and this concept is the same
even in Hindu scriptures that almighty
God has disigned he has assigned how
will human being live this Falls in
short the similarities
between the six pillars of IM in
Hinduism let us discuss the various
similarities between Islam and Hinduism
Allah says in the Quran in Sur MAA
chapter number five verse number 190
Allah
says you
believe most certain toxic against
gambling dedication of stone of arrows
Shan these are Satan
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper Allah says that
intoxicant gambling divination of arrows
all these are Satan's Endor abstain from
it that we may
Prosper let's analyze what do the Hindu
scriptures have to say about these
things if you read it's mentioned in
Manus smti chapter number
n verse number 235 it says that a person
who is a priest killer who is a liquor
Drinker and who is a person who lies on
the marriage bread of the guru and who's
a thief all of them do major sins and in
manusi chapter number 9 verse number 238
it says that all of these should be
punished and it says that these people
no one should talk to them no one should
sacrifice for them no one should marry
them and all of these people should
leave all the religion and should wander
in the world they should be
excommunicated that means anyone who has
intoxicants according to Manus smiti
they should wander in the world and they
should be excommunicated from all the
religions it is more strict than
Islam and if you read the Hindu
scriptures intoxications had been
prohibited in several places if you read
Manus smiti chapter number
verse number 55 it says that a person
who
drinks and a person who kills the priest
who steals and who sleeps on the
marriage bread of the guru all of them
all those who associate with them all of
them are major Sinners it's further
mentioned that alcohol has been
prohibited Hindu scriptures in several
places including maniti chapter number 7
verse number 47 manusi chapter number 7
verse number 50 in maniti chapter number
9 verse number 225 in rig book number8
himm number two verse number 12 in rig
book Number 8 hymn number 21 verse
number 14 in several places the Hindu
scriptures they prohibit the having of
intoxicants even gambling has been
prohibited in Hindu scriptures in rig
book number 10 himn number 34 Verse
number three it says that a person who
gambles his wife he is left alone
and his mother they hate The Gambler and
no one supports him it's further
mentioned in r book number 10 himy
number 34 Verse number 13 it says that
do not play with the dice rather you you
should do
farming if you do farming even if you
earn less money it will be good for the
year
after if you analyze the Hindu
scriptures they forbid for a person to
gamble it's mentioned in Manus smiti
chapter number
7 verse number 50 it says that a person
who drinks the person who gambles a
person who indulges with wom and hunting
all of them they are the most four major
crimes that a person can
do gambling has been prohibited in
several places in Manti chapter number 7
verse 47 in Manti chapter number 9 verse
number 221 to 28 it's also mentioned in
maniti chapter number 9 verse number
28 the Hindu scriptures also prohibit
fortune telling as Allah says in the
Quran in Sur MAA chapter number 5 verse
number
190 oh you
believe most certain intoxic and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handwork May
Prosper gambling has been prohibited
besides gambling and alcohol even
fortune telling has been prohibited it's
also prohibited Manus smti chapter
number 9 verse number 258 that all those
who do fortune telling they are doing a
sin and verse number 262 says that King
should punish them according to the
severity of the crime Allah also says in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 188 Allah says use not your
wealth as a bait for judges in order you
may eat
other people's wealth bribing has been
prohibited in the Quran even the Hindu
scriptures in Manus smiti chapter number
n verse number 258 that all those who
bribe all those who deal in fraud all of
them are major Sinners and the
punishment is mentioned in SM chapter
number 9: 262 that the king will punish
them depending upon the civility of the
crime furthermore Islam believes in
polygamy
and Allah says in the Quran inaha
chapter number four verse number three
Allah says that marry of a choice in
twos threes or fours but if you can't do
justice marry only
one Quran is the only religious book
which says Mary only one there's no
other religious scripture on the face of
the Earth which says Mary only one all
the other major religious scripture if
you read no religious scripture says Mar
only one if you read the Hindu
scriptures if you read Ram
it says that King dashh the father of
ram he had more than one wife it's
mentioned in Vishnu Sutra chapter number
24 verse number one that a Brahman can
have four
wives if you read Mahabharat Krishna how
many wives he had Krishna had
16,18 wives so if Krishna can have 16,18
wives so why can't be Muslims have up to
four if you
analyze the Hindu scriptures say a Hindu
can marry as many wives as they want it
is the Indian government which has put
up limitation the Indian government has
passed the law in
1954 called as the Hindu Marriage Act
and says that a Hindu can only marry one
wife but the Hindu scriptures say that
the Hindus can marry as many wives as
they want there's no upper limit but the
Indian government has put up a limit
that they can only marry one if you read
the report of the Indian government of
the status of women it's mentioned on
page number 66 and 67 it gives the
statistics of the polygamous marriages
done in a span of 10 years from 1951 to
1961 and the Muslims have done
4.31% of polygamous marriages and the
Hindus have done
5.06% polygamist marriages the reasons
for polygamy has been mention my
cassette on M rights in Islam this fall
in brief regarding the similarities
Hinduism and Islam you can keep on
talking for USS together and for the
complete day but if you analyze because
of the British rule we find that
Hinduism has gone down and especially
the britishers they came to India to to
business and they changed many of the
religious beliefs of the Hindus that's
the reason late towards the 18th century
and 19th century there was a surge of
Hindu reformers and the Pioneer among
the Hindu reformers was the person by
the name Raja Raman
Roy Raja Raman Roy he was from Bengal
and he was born in
1772 and he preached that you should
believe only in one God should not do
idol worship he was against the CL
system and he wrote a book in
183 he learned Persian English as well
as Arabic and in that book he condemned
idol worship he said he does not even
agree in the
AAR and he started a new trust by the
name of Brahma
samaj and this Brahma samaj in the trust
deed he writes that no sculpture no
graven image no picture no painting no
photograph should enter the building
and later on there were many offshoots
of the Brahma sage and all of them there
had the common teachings that almighty
God is one he has got no images there
are no Idols of almighty God almighty
God has got no
AAR they were against idol worship and
regarding believing in the cycle of
birth death and rebirth this was
optional if you want to again believe if
you don't want you don't believe the
other great reformer which is offshoot
of Brahma
was justice
ranad justice
ranad he was a person who started the
prna
samage I hope you're aware of PR samaj
are you aware of prna
sage very good you PR how many of you
know about Justice rad how many of
us this person he started an offshoot of
Brahma samaj and he even preached
against car system he even preached that
the widows the women they should remarry
he even preached that the women should
be
educated the other great reformer among
the Hindu was Swami Dan sarasti he
started in
1875 the Arya
samage and the three pundits they Marya
samaj what he said that we should
strictly follow the
vas and and we should not follow
anything but the vas believe in one God
that you should not do idol worship
should not believe that God has
gotar he started the
Arya we even have one more famous
reformer by the name of Swami he was the
founder of Sri ramakrishan
Mission and he said that Hinduism is a
misn NOA we should call the followers as
vedantist and he made Hinduism common to
the Western world where he gave a talk
in Chicago in the parliament of
religion we find that many Hindu
reformers were there they tried to
improve the teachings of
Hinduism and today we come to know from
history that the
britishers they had come to India to do
business they came to India about a few
centuries back they came for doing
business but they looted our country
they even ruled our country and these
britishers they changed the religious
belief of the
Indians and these people they saw to it
that they change the philosophy of
Hinduism so we find a surge of Hindu
reformers especially in the late 18th
century and the 19th century for example
as I mentioned Raja Raman
Ro example of
vianda example of Swami Dan and sarasti
Justice an and these people they were
reformers and people may
wonder that all these things that I
mentioned my talk about the facts of
Hinduism that I mentioned they weren't
concoction but I received all these
guidance about Hinduism from these great
reformers like Raja Ram mroy and Jus
anad and after I read this book these
people are great Scholars I'm just a
student of comparative religion I'm not
a scholar when I read the books of these
Scholars I being a student of
comparative religion I don't take
anything for granted whatever they said
I checked up whether are they available
in the sacred scripture of the Hindus
and after verifying them I have
mentioned the facts of Hinduism while
quoting the references of the Hindu
scriptures and all the facts I mentioned
about
Hinduism I have also mentioned the
references from the
vas as well as the other scriptures like
upanishad like bhagwad Gita etc those
Hindus who strictly Believe In The Vedas
they don't believe in any other
scripture of Hinduism so even if you
remove all the other reference of the
Hindu
scriptures whatever references have
given I have quoted The Vedas as well as
the other scriptures if you remove the
reference of the other scriptures yet
the message of Hinduism is the same
there are other Hindus though they
believe that Veda is the most sacred
among the Hindu scriptures but they even
believe in the other scriptures and they
more commonly read bhagad Gita Etc
that's the reason I've even quoted the
vas even the other Hindu
scriptures I have been enlightened by
the great reformers of Hinduism
and from history we have come to
know that the
britishers they ruled India by having a
philosophy of divide and
Rule with this philosophy they ruled
India for several
years we
alhamdulillah more than 50 years back we
have got the freedom of this
country from the rule of the
British but unfortunately
we yet continue following the philosophy
of the britishers of divide and
Rule and we have
examples that most of the Indian
politicians they follow the philosophy
of the britishers
and they have the philosophy of divide
and rule for the world
Banks and we find that in this country
of us the maximum rats in any country of
the world it's in India
and the cause that these politician they
instigate these rights they follow the
philosophy of divide and Rule and many
people say that the
politicians they add fuel to the fire I
disagree the politicians of India they
don't add fuel to the fire these people
they add fire to the fuel
[Applause]
we know that the fuel is used for
constructive work for
vehicles for factories for upliftment of
India but these people they add fire to
the fuel and they cause the destruction
of India all the politician aren't like
that but most of them they add fire to
the fuel and they use it as a vote
Bank most of them if not all
irrespective whether they Hindu
politicians Muslim politicians or
Christian
politicians and there's article which
came